so one of the chain reactions to the
firing of Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson which we spoke about yesterday
is that CIA director Mike Pompeo is
going to replace Tillerson as Secretary
of State presumably and that will lead
to Mike Pompeo being replaced by the
deputy CIA director Gina Haspel and this
is a big problem we should be very very
concerned about Gina Haspel becoming CIA
director Yale Law Professor Asha ranga
when this news broke tweeted an article
talking about why torture is really bad
for national security where she said
since miss torture is poised to had the
CIA reaping this piece which explains
why those policies were bad for natural
national security miss torture the
reason why Gina Haspel is being referred
to as miss torture is that she was
hugely involved in the 2002 torture of
detainees at a CIA prison in Thailand
and also of the cover-up of that torture
after overseeing the torture itself she
was involved in an order to destroy
videotapes and records of that torture
at that same tie prison detention
facility and she is sort of a throwback
I guess I'd call it to one of the darker
recent eras for the United States in
terms of how we treated how we have
treated detainees the era of Abu Ghraib
the era of the torture report and when
we learned about all the horrible things
we were doing the detainees and over the
last several years we've seen somewhat
of a move away from that direction not a
total move away but somewhat of a move
away and putting Gina Haspel in there is
sort of a wink and a nod to that era of
horrific treatment of detainees by the
United States remember when Abu Zubaydah
was waterboarded 83 times in a month
Gina Haspel was overseeing that and she
oversaw as I mentioned the destruction
of evidence of those interrogations so
this is disturbing and should concern us
for two different reasons one is that if
you promote Haspel
you might be signaling a return to or at
least sort of deference to the torture
era if we believe we're not in the
torture era anymore which is sort of
unclear but the other signal that is
sent when you take someone who oversaw
and covered up some of the worst
behavior by American intelligence in
recent history and make them CIA
director is that it's still not even
really taken that seriously that's what
you're implying
if what Haspel oversaw and participated
in was taken seriously if it was truly a
non-negotiable just the US will not in
any way even implicitly condone what was
done she wouldn't have been deputy CIA
director before and soon to be CIA
director now period yeah this is why I
don't think it's it's right to normalize
the Bush administration mm-hmm not only
because that was a dark chapter in
American history but also because those
career officials are still around if
they served in Bush's administration
they could also serve in Trump
administration too he's a Republican as
well yeah we know john bolton who was
the architect of the iraq war or at
least one of them he maybe Trump's next
national security adviser and that's
very and not that some of them didn't
serve under Obama right we don't have to
skip from Bush to trump this this did
not go away under Obama and it's a
signal of the exact wrong values that
the US should be it's a signal of the
values that the United States should not
be promoting or even seeming to be
implicitly condoning and as reminders
these are sort of the boiler plates that
I like to include in any story about
torture and these so-called enhanced
interrogation techniques we know torture
doesn't work we know it's
counterproductive we know people will
say and do whatever they believe they
need to say to get the torture to stop
and is also illegal under US and
international law and treaty and if we
are the country of the rule of law which
Trump I guess says we are we should be
against it and obviously it's laughable
to think that under Donald Trump we are
the country of law and order yeah do you
think there's a chance that Haspel won't
get confirmed by the Senate I think
that's their only chance at this point I
think that that is the only chance and I
think there is no chance I think that
she is absolutely going
be confirmed and we are quickly moving
down here downhill here it's getting
worse and worse and it doesn't just stop
the there's a couple of moves that are
happening as a result of the firing of
Rex Tillerson Jeana Haspel from deputy
CIA director to CIA director is bad but
I also want to talk about what's going
to happen with the guy that's moving
from CIA director potentially to
Secretary of State the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership